you were still like
on some pretty hard drugs until at least
95 right no man oh no no
sober wow okay i was sober in 89.
wow and then how old are you then you're
like 20 or something i was 18 18. and
you've got some correcting to do on
wikipedia oh dude wikipedia is whacked
don't get me started right all right
no no no no no get me started
let me tell you about this okay let's
talk let's be real i've got i've got
some [ __ ] on wikipedia i'm on media
blackout do you know what media blackout
means
it means that there's actually people
out there that are working on a 24-hour
basis to discredit and defame me and
change the facts of life
so
there you know wikipedia is supposed to
be an open forum where anybody user
friendly can go in there and edit
whatever they want right which leaves
you open to the truth it also leaves you
open to lies right that's what you would
think but if me or anybody on my team
tries to go into wikipedia you can try
it right now and you try to edit
something
it'll stick for about two minutes and
then it goes back and reverts to
whatever the [ __ ] was that was there
okay then like if it's me and i try to
say like multiple times two or three
times all of a sudden i get a notice up
that says i'm blocked my ip address is
blocked for the next two years wow and
anybody that tries to even try to change
wikipedia no remember being on a cookie
you should be able to the way that that
that whole program is set up the way
that the website works is it's a
user-friendly basis which means that
anybody with a computer and any
you know basic knowledge of html can get
in there and edit it and show the links
that they need to show to show the truth
and like it should all back up because
somebody's got to go through it and go
like oh this makes sense this points to
this
but they have some kind of system
on mine maybe yours i don't know i mean
i don't know how truthful yours is
they're off you're i mean it's just like
you know it says i've been married twice
and i've actually never been married
right so that's fresh are they allowed
to do that
yeah good question right especially when
they're purposefully blocking your ip
address or anybody associated with you
so yeah wikimedia is the company that
owns wikipedia and we're probably going
to have to like send them some very
serious letters from our lawyers because
this is not acceptable they're out there
lying about me everything on women like
what's the malicious lie the malicious
lie is like you just said there's you
know they say that i wasn't really sober
one of the things says that i went on
the today show in october and then two
months later i was arrested in louisiana
let me tell you something i was never
arrested in louisiana
right that was flash i was not arrested
members of my band were arrested and
that was all for having me
and a half a xanax pill
okay
not my xanax bill not my weed i wasn't
arrested let's just be real so the
bottom line is there's people out there
maliciously intentionally trying to make
me sound like a liar
trying to change my
credibility okay because obviously if
i'm lying about this or if i'm lying
about that then those really important
big stories that i told in my
documentary must not be true because
obviously i'm a liar yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town
with my bucket list tour what is it well
it's an x-rated show full of all the
stuff that i would have never been
allowed to do for jackass and a lot of
it is flagrantly illegal so it's adults
only and if you live in any of these
states then you better go to stevo.com
and check out my tour schedule hurry up
and get your tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]